hi my name is lauren graham and i play
alex morrow
hi i'm brittany newton and i play
mmorrow hi i'm maxwell simpkins and i
play nick
hi i'm swayam bhatia and i play sophie
hansonbot we're the cast of the mighty
ducks game changers
we're here with buzzfeed today to find
out which combination of original
and new mighty ducks characters we
actually are
[Music]
how would your friends describe you fun
goofy confident talented outspoken
grumpy i'm going with fun i feel like
i'm goofy and i'm fine i'm confident and
talented and i'm outspoken and i'm
grumpy i don't know i
have a lot of talents so i think you're
goofy talented or fun
i'd say very much oh thank you
definitely talented as well
thank you all right i'll go talk to it
how about you guys sway i think you
should oscar talented
i don't know everything anyone can think
of
okay i think you're fun fun
talented yeah one of the two are we all
going for talented maybe i
don't know i'll go talented then you're
naming a new hockey team what do you
pick
the wacky wombats the silly geese the
underdogs
the leaping lizards the cool cats and
the skating sharks
i'm going with the underdogs because
it's the one that didn't have an
alliterative
partner and because i think i could
design
like a sad looking dog for our jerseys
i'm going with the shirts
that's cool i'll go with the other i
like yeah i like the underdogs too but
like i also like the cool cat
i'm a dog person so i'm gonna go with
the underdog now choose your favorite
color for your hockey jerseys
red blue purple yellow orange green
i would go with blue blue is my favorite
color blue
on the ice will really be a nice
contrast
i'm going with blue blue yeah blue baby
all day
yeah blue pick a fictional duck donald
duck daisy duck daffy duck scrooge
mcduck rubber ducky howie
louie and dewey i'm going to go with the
ducktales
here's the thing huey dewey and louie
are great characters
but scrooge mcduck went on adventures
and he also became rich and he's like a
businessman i think i'm going between
donald duck and daisy does but honestly
donald's going to daisy doe they're
going to go for daisy though because
honestly she's super fashionable
i am picking rubber ducky because it's
the only ducky
i know of that has its own song choose a
show to binge watch
gilmore girls full house babysitters
club
julian the phantoms wand division or the
mandalorian
i was in gilmore girls so i'm
going to pick the mandalorian they have
cute aliens
oh i'm easily going to the mandalorian
huge star wars fan
really sorry lauren but i'm going for
the mandalorian
i binge watched gilmore girls but i also
love
wanda vision white vision's a great show
i'm
gonna go for one division because i just
want to represent disney flaws but i
love you lauren
and i love gilmore girls pick something
important from mighty ducks game
changers
ice palace the don't bothers the
wraparound podcast
alex's meltdown video flying v and video
games
the rapper podcast you know what it is
that's the best frightening yeah
sorry max i'm like what so wrap around
podcast is the second
biggest uh youth hockey podcast in
southeastern minnesota
are there only two i'm going between ice
palace and the flying v
honestly like the ice house is my second
home you guys should listen to the
wraparound
i'm gonna go with the ice palette i
picked the wrap around i
just really enjoyed the hosts of the
wrap around i love that maxwell
and uh yeah i go with the wrap around
finally pick a quote from the original
mighty ducks movies
quack quack quack duck fly together i'm
the lady
i'm a duck forget it cake eater keep
swimming you maybe will give them a cold
i will not quack at the principal i'm no
lady i'm a duck
i would do ducks fly together because
when we were leaving
ducks fly together was like the one
thing we all said and that has a deep
place in my heart
ducks fly together i'm gonna go i will
not quack at the principal because it's
absolutely funny
obviously i'm no lady i'm a duck what's
a sassier thing to say to someone
we all got guys remaining here why do we
all get kiefer
i got charlie conway and evan marrow
who's my
kid so that's a good result good job
buzzfeed
i'm retaking i'm trying to get myself i
want to try to get myself too
oh i did it i got connie and sophie i
got abram
in this let's go like lester and nick
you're lit enough every room with your
sense of humor but it's telling jokes at
practice at practice or on the wrap
around
yeah let's go like like connie and
sophie you're an amazing teammate
on and off the ranks of skilled smart
and kind
let's go i got myself you're like
charlie conaway or evan mara like evan
and charlie you never expect to be a
leader but it turns out you're a pretty
great one
all right thank you buzzfeed make sure
to watch the mighty ducks game changers
on disney plus
you